[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN BOYD: Hello everyone.
My name is Ryan Boyd.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I'm
Michael Manoochehri.
RYAN BOYD: And this is the
Michael and Ryan Show.
Today we're here to talk about
best practices for querying
massive datasets using
Google BigQuery.
If you have any questions that
come up while you're listening
to this or watching this
broadcast, feel free to reach
out to us on Stack Overflow in
the google-bigquery tag, or
find us on the Google Cloud
Platform Developers+ page, or
at our Google+ profiles and
Twitter handles here.
We welcome to hear for
your feedback.
All right, so, querying massive
datasets with Google BigQuery.
First of all, let's give you
a little bit of history.
It used to be when people wanted
to query their data
sets, they would load their
data into a relational
database server that looked
something like this.
That relational database server
would get basically all
of their data, and it
would build indexes
on top of that data.
And those indexes made it quick
to query things that you
knew in advance that you wanted
to be able to query.
So if you wanted to do some
aggregate queries on that
data, it might be OK too, based
off of those indexes,
but if you want to do really ad
hoc queries to explore your
data and understand your data
better, you'd often end up
doing something called
a full table scan.
Now, a full table scan is
basically reading every single
row of your data from disk
and processing each row
individually.
Now, this is fine if you have
a small dataset, but as you
grow your data and you have,
say, hundreds of millions of
rows or billions of rows of
data, you can only scale your
relational database servers
so large and
in a vertical fashion.
And Google really had a
challenge internally.
We had a challenge that we
needed to be able to query
these types of massive
datasets in
an interactive style.
We needed to get results
quickly, because those fast
results help us iterate on our
products which are necessary
for us to build our business.
So Google said, well, what
if we don't use a typical
relational database server.
What if we don't rely upon this
concept of indexes, but
instead embrace the concept of a
full table scan, embrace the
idea that we are going
to query over every
single row of our data.
What would we need to
make that happen?
Well, Google already had tens,
hundreds, thousands of servers
around the world, and these
servers had thousands of disks
in them as well.
And disk performance is one
of the key things that's
necessary in order to query
massive amounts of data.
Now, you can parallelize the
queries across all of these
machines using typical big data
processing techniques
such as the MapReduce
algorithm,
which Google invented.
But the MapReduce algorithm and
other big data techniques
often times are batch-based.
They basically allow you to
query your data or process
your data in batches, and those
batches can sometimes
take minutes, or hours, or
even days to get results.
Google really needed to have
that interactive query speed,
so we decided to invent a
new technology, and that
technology internally
is known as Dremel.
And externally, we've released
this to you to use as Google
BigQuery, as a service.
We built an API and some
developer usability features
on top of the internal
service.
So here's what BigQuery
looks like.
We wanted to give you an idea
of what BigQuery looks like,
what the architecture is, so you
can better understand when
you're running your queries
what's happening.
At the bottom of this diagram
is distributed storage.
So your data sits on this
distributed storage and is
read off of the disks
by leaf nodes.
And each leaf node only reads
a small chunk of your data.
Each of these leaf nodes would
be a CPU or a machine, and
they're only responsible for
reading that small chunk.
And each of them processes
their small chunk
individually.
And as the data flows up the
tree through the mixers, the
data is aggregated.
So if you think about something
like account.
The two leaves on the left hand
side would each count the
number of records that they're
responsible for, in the data
set that they're responsible
for, and then the mixer, as it
goes up the tree, would actually
sum those two counts.
It's a very simple operation.
Now, what's important here is
that we're reading from the
distributed storage only at
the bottom of the tree.
We're not reading and writing
from the distributed storage
throughout the process, as
is typically done in a
MapReduce-based algorithm.
What's also important
here is this is a
long-lived serving tree.
This serving tree exists for
all of your queries as a
customer, and also
exists for the
queries of other customers.
So it sits around ready
to process your
queries very quickly.
The other thing that I want to
point out is we use a thing
called columnar storage.
Basically, we're storing
the data in columns
rather than in rows.
So as we read the data off of
disk, oftentimes you will only
need to read very particular
columns.
Usually when you're running a
query-- think of a SQL-like
syntax, which is what we
use for BigQuery--
you're only selecting particular
columns and using
your WHERE clause on
particular columns.
So we only need to read
those particular
columns off of disks.
This saves us a lot of our
operations, and we'll see how
it does that here shortly.
All right, so hopefully you
understand a little bit about
how BigQuery works in the
underlying architecture.
Now let's dive into some of
the types of queries that
BigQuery can process.
And the first one I want to
talk about here is regular
expressions.
So regular expressions is
something that all good geeks
know and love, and have worked
with back since I started
programming on Perl when I first
started development, and
regular expressions
are obviously very
well known in Perl.
But regular expressions
are powerful ways of
working with text.
Now, the thing with regular
expressions, though, is you're
changing them often.
When you're trying to do these
exploration of your data,
you're changing those regular
expressions, so you can't
build typical indexes on
it like would work in a
relational database.
So most relational databases,
if you're running regular
expressions, you're going to
be doing those and doing a
full table scan when you write
those regular expressions or
if you have to modify them.
So this is a very powerful
feature that I
want to show you.
BigQuery supports regular
expressions using matches,
replacements, or extractions,
supports all these new
different types of regular
expressions.
Let's show you where that power
really lies when you're
trying to query not just, say,
tens of millions or tens of
thousands of rows of data, but
if you're doing billions of
rows of data.
So I'm going to start running
this query over here, and this
is doing an aggregate analysis
on 15.7 billion rows of data.
So this is 15.7 billion rows,
and we're actually going to do
a regular expression on every
single one of these rows.
So we can see a regex match.
This dataset basically
represents
something like a log file.
In this case, it's a log file
of page views on Wikipedia,
but imagine in your case it
might be a log file of
activity on your website or
clicks, or views on your ads
that you place.
And so this log file has titles
in it, and those titles
represent the page
that was viewed.
In this case, we want to do a
regular expression to find all
of those pages that start with
a capital G and with a
lowercase e, and have
two o's in between.
I wonder what that spells out.
So we can see that we ran
this regular expression.
There's 13 tables here.
It represents one terabyte of
underlying data, and we ran
this regular expression
in 34 seconds.
So that was 15.7 billion regular
expressions run in 34
seconds across a terabyte
of data in the tables.
And because of the columnar data
store, we actually only
had to process about 665
gigabytes of data, but it's
still a massive amount of data
to find the result that
Google, over the year 2010 and
the first month of 2011, was
the most popular viewed
Wikipedia page with, I think
that's 1.7 million views if
I'm reading that right.
And we see some other
pages here as well.
But the important thing to
emphasize here is we're
running that 15.7
billion regular
expressions in 34 seconds.
Imagine trying to do that in
your typical relational
database server, or
even if using the
MapReduce-type algorithm.
It would require a lot of
processing power, and may not
even be possible then.
All right.
So that gives you an idea
of the types of regular
expressions and the power of
BigQuery to run queries on
massive datasets.
Now I'm going to throw it over
to Michael here, and Michael's
going to talk about the next
section here, which is
statistical queries.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.,
so statistical queries are
another example of the type
of query that challenges
relational databases when the
data sizes are large.
And also, if you're using
something like a document
store or NoSQL database or any
kind of actual database where
you have a distributed system,
generally to get statistical
aggregate queries--
and I'm talking about things
like counts, averages, even
standard deviations and things
like quantiles--
generally you'll have
to write a MapReduce
function of your own.
What's great about BigQuery is
that you can express these
types of queries using SQL
or SQL-like language that
BigQuery supports.
So let's take a look
at some examples.
We're going to take a look at
a public dataset we have in
BigQuery that you have access
to when you sign up.
And that's the natality
dataset.
So this is a really interesting
data set.
It's a record of births in
the United States, and a
collection of data with mother's
age, father's age,
the baby weight, and other
statistics about the birth.
And I think we have several
decades of this data.
I think millions and
millions of rows of
data actually, obviously.
So let's take a look at some
queries using some of the
statistical functions that
BigQuery supports.
It can give you a sense of the
types of queries you can do.
So we're going to come back
to our BigQuery UI.
Now, this is a query that we
were interested in looking at,
if there's some kind of variance
between the baby
weights of women who
smoke and those who
don't during gestation.
And so here we're going to run
a query to find the average
baby weight and the average
mother's age.
And we just picked
a random state.
We're just going to pick Ohio,
and we're going to group by if
the mothers smoked cigarettes
or not.
So let's run this query.
This is going to give you a
sense of the aggregates over
these large data sets.
And that was a very
quick result.
And as you can see, there is
a difference in baby weight
between the fact that if
a mother smoked or not.
And the joke I always talk to
Ryan about is is this of
statistical significance.
So if you had a statistical
package like R, you could
actually do some kind
of correlation.
Here I also ran a standard
deviation to give you a sense
of that as well.
And so this was running over
gigabytes of data, and if you
were using a relational
database, this
would take some time.
So let's take a look at another
statistical query.
In this case, we're going to do
the count of baby births by
gender for large states.
So I've actually picked
a number that's, I
think, three million.
So we're going to look at states
that have had over
three million births.
I think there's only going to
be California and Texas in
this example.
But here I'm highlighting
another interesting function,
and that's HAVING.
HAVING is like using WHERE in a
normal SQL clause, but here
we're looking at the
aggregate result.
So here I'm going to say, give
me all of the count of baby
births by gender having a count
over three million.
Let's run that.
And here we're going to
show gender disparity
between large states.
And this should actually come
back pretty quickly as well.
So here you can see, here's the
state of California and
the state of Texas, and you
can see the difference of
birth genders between
the two states.
So, again, a ton of data.
We're whipping through this
really fast, and it's easy to
express these types of queries
in BigQuery's language.
Now here's one.
This is one of my favorites.
I'm going to look at a standard
deviation, and here
we're going to use BigQuery to
find outliers in this dataset.
So I was interested to see how
large does a baby have to be
to be several standard
deviations above the mean.
And I just randomly
picked four.
I wanted to see if there were
any babies that were four
standard deviations
above the mean.
So you can run that across the
entire dataset of US births,
and very quickly the
result comes back.
That's a baby that's about 12
pounds, almost 13 pounds, is a
baby that's four standard
deviations above the mean.
That's a pretty chubby baby.
So I took this number, and I
wanted to do a quick ad hoc
query to see what months and
which states were the
chubbiest babies born in.
So actually what's great about
BigQuery is you can run these
ad hoc aggregate queries.
So let's take that number
and put it back
into another query.
And here I'm just going to
group by state, year, and
month, and I'm going to see
which state for which date
were the fattest babies born.
Or let's say the most
giant babies.
And so shockingly, Maryland in
December 1990 had quite a lot
of very chubby babies.
Actually I went to Google
to see what was going.
I couldn't find a definitive
answer, so if anyone has any
idea why Maryland in December
1990 had such chubby babies,
please let me know.
But these are the kind of
queries you can do that are
very difficult on other systems,
and are pretty easy
and quick with BigQuery.
So let's take a look at some
other functions that
BigQuery's really good at.
Earlier, Ryan talked about
some of the log data.
We were looking at Wikipedia
page view data.
BigQuery's excellent
for log data.
It's one of the canonical
use cases for it.
So it has certain specific
functions that help you format
and parse time stamps
and URLs and IPs.
So you can do things like take a
UTC formatted time stamp and
format it into a more human
readable string.
We have functions
to parse URLs.
So if you're looking at domains,
grouping things by
domains, that's really easy.
And you can parse and format IP
addresses and convert them
from integers back into
a string format,
and things like that.
So let's do a few quick examples
just to show you what
I'm talking about.
Let's go back to our BigQuery
web UI, and we're going to
take a look at a quick
domain query.
So this is a really interesting
public dataset we
have as well.
One of our colleagues Ilya,
who's on the Chrome team, he
was really interested in
GitHub public data.
So he loaded up a bunch of the
data from the GitHub Public
Timeline, which is great stuff
like repository homepage,
commit message, really
cool stuff.
And we have some examples
on our website in our
documentation about ways you
can query this and do some
interesting, what I call the
poor man's sentiment analysis,
by studying commit string
messages and things like that.
You can find the most
popular projects.
So in this case, what we're
doing is we're just going to
look at the project
homepage domains
with the most activity.
So in GitHub you can
say, this is my
home page for my project.
And oftentimes it is GitHub.
So let's just take a
quick look at this.
I'm using the domain function,
and I'm grouping by domain.
So here you can see people
have with the domain
github.com, which is the most
common, google.com, that might
even be code.google.com,
Khan Academy Mozilla.
So you can do these kind of
analyses on your logs to find
out, for example, referrers,
like what is the most common
referrer, et cetera.
So really useful stuff when
it comes to logs and IP.
And let's do a quick time
stamp query as well.
We're going to take a quick
look at this one.
This is an interesting one.
Going back to our Wikipedia
dataset, I was interested in
knowing what moment in time
the most edited pages are.
So here's an example.
I just randomly chose Obama.
I wanted to see what moment, to
the second, were the most
edits made to pages containing
the name Obama.
So you can actually do these
kind of queries with BigQuery.
This is going to look through
gigabytes and
gigabytes of data.
And I found out that on
7/29/2008 at a particular
time, there were five revisions
being made.
And it's really interesting to
see this kind of stuff happen.
You can bucket by time when
revisions are being made, and
find really interesting
visualizations and interesting
graphs using this
type of data.
So really interesting
stuff there.
This is one of the most common
questions we get are
geospatial queries.
Ever since we both started the
project, almost every time we
meet developers they
ask us about this.
So we made a special effort
to talk a little bit about
geospatial queries in our Query
Cookbook documentation.
So this is a really interesting
one, and I think
Ryan has been playing a lot with
geospatial queries with
your car data.
We did some automotive data
analysis, and we can talk
about that on another GL.
It's on our videos page where
we talk about sensor data.
So let's do a few examples
of geospatial queries.
So BigQuery has a lot of
mathematical functions besides
the statistical aggregate
mathematical functions.
Cosine, sine, trigonometric
functions, rounding functions,
all kinds of things.
So you can actually use these
functions to do things like
approximate a bounding
circle using
some of the trig functions.
And of course you can
do a range for the
bounding box as well.
So let's take a look at some
of those examples.
We have some here.
Let's take a quick look.
So let's look at a geospatial
bounding box.
This is a pretty simple one.
We're going to take a latitude
and longitude, and we're going
to find a range in between the
boundaries of this latitude
and longitude grouping.
And here we're going to
look at San Francisco.
We both live in San Francisco,
and we're going to look at the
average temperature from
weather station data.
We have an interesting
dataset in BigQuery.
It's the general surface
summary data.
So every day, all the weather
stations that are public
collect data, and this is a
dataset set of all of that
data that we have available
since, I think it's
like 1929 or 1930.
So millions and millions
of records.
Really interesting stuff.
What we did was we took this
data, and we attached a
latitude and longitude
to each station.
And here we're able to actually
run these geospatial
queries and get aggregate
results for any station that
falls within a certain
geographic range.
It's really interesting.
So here we're going to run a
query around San Francisco,
and we're going to group by
year and month, and we're
going to produce a listing of
the average temperature, and
also the minimum and maximum
over a range.
And here that was a very quick
query, just a few seconds over
gigabytes of data.
And this is another kind of
query that would be great for
a visualization.
You can actually bucket by year
or month, produce the
average, the minimum, the max,
very interesting for that
specific range.
So really good query there.
Now let's do a bounding
circle.
Now Ryan, we spent a lot of time
trying to learn about the
bounding circle.
Can you tell us a little bit
about how this bounding circle
query works?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
Basically, the bounding circle
query is just using basic trig
functions, and assuming
that the world
is perfectly spherical.
The world isn't perfectly
spherical, so you won't get
totally accurate results if
you're near the poles, but
oftentimes, this type of
bounding circle query is
actually adequate for most
places in the world.
So it's a pretty interesting
query to run.
You can see all the trig
functions that we're using.
And why don't we kickoff
that query here.
And we're finding the average
temperature for all the
weather stations that are around
Denver, Colorado, in
this particular query.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And
this is actually for
the month of January.
We picked Denver because there's
a wide variation of
weather between winter
and summer.
So as you can see here, this
will produce the distance away
from this middle of the
circle, along with the
latitude and longitude of the
weather station and the
temperature as well, which
is really interesting.
So you can see the temperatures
here are pretty cold.
To just give you an example of
the cool things you can do,
you can switch this up
to June or July.
Let's take July.
RYAN BOYD: So we're about 30
degrees or so, I believe, in
Fahrenheit.
So switching to July, what
do we end up with here?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Should be warmer.
RYAN BOYD: 70-ish.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Sounds pretty good.
Very mild, very great.
Love to be in Denver then.
Looks good.
So this exact example is on
our Query Cookbook on the
Google Developers page for
BigQuery, and I hope you check
it out if you're interested
in this type of query.
All right.
So let's talk about nested
and repeated data.
So to get your data into
BigQuery, you have to ingest
source files.
And your source files can
be in CSV data, which is
rectangular, log-shaped data
fits into this very well, but
you can also ingest JSON data.
And JSON data can model a nested
and repeated dataset.
So let me just show you a
little bit what I mean.
Here's an example
I like to use.
I call it the social music
store dataset.
So in this case, imagine a
social music store where you
have a lot of customers, and
they can either listen to or
purchase music.
And your logs will record
each of these events.
So here's an example of, Michael
is listening to a
song, and he decides to
purchase the song.
The two types of data, listening
and purchasing, have
different data types in that,
when you listen, it doesn't
cost anything.
So you're not recording
a cost.
And when you purchase something,
you're actually
buying it, so there's a cost
associated with that.
And so you could model this in
a flat, CSV-style format.
But as you can see, there's
redundancy,
there's some null values.
You may have to have a separate
field for listen and
purchase, like a flag
that describes it.
So this works.
There's nothing wrong with it,
and BigQuery can actually
handle this type of data, if
this is how you have it.
But imagine another way, maybe
a different way to model this
data to give you some
added advantages.
And I'll talk about
that in a second.
So you can actually take that
rectangular data and model it
like this, in a nested
and repeated way.
So every day, I can actually
have a top level record called
Michael, and it can show
my activities.
So in this case, I've
highlighted the listens, and
that is a separate model, a
separate type of record, and
then below it is purchases.
So as you can see, there's a
cost associated with it.
Basically, I can have two
different types of records
within this Michael record.
So what does this mean?
So why is there an
advantage here?
Well, there's actually
several.
RYAN BOYD: I just want to say
I mean, it's actually a much
more natural way to model the
data rather than flatting it
out, and it's also a way
that's used by a lot of
standard NoSQL databases and
other databases to model data.
So that makes BigQuery really
compatible if you're trying to
analyze your massive dataset
that's stored in a typical
NoSQL database.
You can load it into BigQuery
and run the
aggregate queries there.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: No doubt.
As I was saying before, this
is a big advantage.
And if you're using something
like Mongo, you can actually
export the data as JSON.
It's the native file
format for some of
those documents stores.
So really easy to get the data
into BigQuery that way.
But actually this kind of
structure, this nested and
repeated structure, supports
some additional query
functionality which
is really useful.
One is WITHIN RECORD.
So in this case, what you can do
is actually find aggregate
data within a specific record.
And I'll explain how that
works in a second.
The other is POSITION.
If you ingest your data in a
nested way with repeated
values, BigQuery actually
remembers the position of each
one, so you can do cool things
like playlists and show the
position of a song
in a playlist.
And I'll give you an example
in a second.
Just to give you an idea, this
is the kind of query.
How many users have
listened to a
particular artist, for example.
This kind of query you can
actually say, well, the count
of people that listen to this
particular artist in this
playlist, you could have a full
count, an aggregate over
the entire dataset, or you can
actually use WITHIN RECORD to
actually pull out the average
for each individual user,
which is super useful.
And here's an example of what
position is a particular
artist's song in a daily
user playlist.
Here I'm using the POSITION
function to
actually pull that out.
I have some sample data.
Have a fake music store, and we
can actually look at some
of these queries in action.
So let's start with the
WITHIN RECORD query.
In my fake music store, I'm
going to run a subquery to
find users who are listening
to the artist PSY, and I'm
going to find the count within
record of PSY's songs.
So let's see.
It's a pretty small dataset, but
in this case, you can see
I have apparently two PSY
songs in my playlist.
I didn't know there was another
popular PSY song, but
it's in there.
And now let's take a
look at position.
So this is very interesting.
I'm going to look at
the actual position
of a song in a playlist.
As you saw, I may have multiple
songs by a particular
artist in my playlist.
Now here I can say, find
the actual position.
So you can see in this case,
each of the users in our
dataset has the song in
a different position.
This is very useful, for
example, if you want to know
things like bouncing.
Like when people come to your
site, when do they bounce out?
You can use playlist data
or shopping data.
What kind of things are people
buying in sequence?
There's a lot of applications
for this type of query, and
it's actually supported by
BigQuery using nested and
repeated data.
So yeah.
So I think that pretty much
wraps up our querying session.
A lot of the queries you saw
today are available in our
Query Cookbook, which is on
developers.google.com/bigquery.
And of course we want
to hear from you.
We want to know what kind of
things you're doing, and what
kind of queries you're
running, what
you'd like to see.
If there's a query you're having
trouble with, of course
Stack Overflow is a good
place for that.
Post your question using the
google-bigquery tag, and some
of our engineers are on that
site all the time and we'll
get back to you as
soon as we can.
RYAN BOYD: I think that
about wraps it up.
I'm Ryan.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I'm Michael.
RYAN BOYD: And this is the
Michael and Ryan Show.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]